Trascrizione: Chiara Rossini
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Se dovessi chiedervi
che cos'è per voi la casa
sono sicuro che sentirei
delle risposte molto differenti.
Per me, per esempio,
la casa è un bel posto vicino al mare.
Per mia madre ad esempio,
sarebbe un posto in città.
Una cosa che io non potrei concepire.
Ma, questo mi fa capire che la casa
è, quindi, un concetto molto relativo.
Quando gli amici del TEDX
mi hanno chiesto di parlare della casa
sono andato su Wikipedia
e ho cercato cos'era la casa.
Testualmente dice: "Per casa si intende
una qualunque struttura
utilizzata per ripararsi
dagli agenti atmosferici".
Ho pensato, allora:
"Ma se lo chiedessi agli amici delfini?"
Loro certo non si devono riparare
dagli agenti atmosferici.
Allora ho capito che questo
è un concetto ancora più relativo.
Se lo dovessi chiedere a Neil Armstrong,
quando era sulla Luna?
Che cos'è la casa per lui in quel momento?
Con il dito
mi indicherebbe un puntino blu.
È la Terra.
Casa nostra è il pianeta Terra.
E se lo guardiamo da lassù,
Neil Armstrong lo vedeva
proprio come un puntino blu,
perché per il 70% è costituito da acqua,
o meglio è ricoperto da acqua.
Cosa abbiamo fatto noi per custodire
questa importantissima casa?
Ben poco.
Le nostre spiagge parlano chiarissimo,
vediamo che c'è veramente
tantissima plastica,
tantissimo inquinamento.
È un po' come quando noi
abbiamo degli ospiti a casa
non li portiamo certo a vedere --
se li porto a vedere il mio stanzino
sono sicuro che si metterebbero
le mani nei capelli.
Ma anche con la pesca,
molto spesso incontrollata, illegale
si fanno dei danni molto gravi
per la nostra casa.
A farmelo capire è stato un piccolo,
grande capodoglio, nel 2017.
Il capodoglio è rimasto imprigionato
in una rete illegale
al largo delle Isole Eolie.
La Guardia Costiera
ha cercato di liberarlo
ma purtroppo non ci è riuscita,
Il capodoglio è andato via.
Tutti quanti sui social speravamo
che il capodoglio potesse tornare a vivere
tranquillo e libero nel suo mare.
Purtroppo, il giorno dopo scopriamo
che il capodoglio arriva, morto,
a Capo Milazzo, con la corrente.
Allora decisi di andare immediatamente
a guardare questo enorme capodoglio.
Il primo impatto che ho avuto con lui era
-- potete immaginare,
era in basso in una scogliera,
era l'impatto con il naso.
Io già da lontano sentivo
questo fortissimo odore
del capodoglio in putrefazione,
lo vedete già dalla foto.
Man mano che mi avvicinavo,
l'odore diventava sempre più forte
e alla mia vista si apriva questa enorme
massa di carne in putrefazione, morta.
Ma guardandolo negli occhi,
c'era qualcosa che mi diceva
che il capodoglio non era del tutto morto.
Lo sentivo in qualche modo vivo,
mi parlava, mi chiedeva aiuto,
mi chiedeva
di non farlo morire nuovamente,
di farlo in qualche modo tornare a vivere,
per parlare di come era morto,
per evitare che altri capodogli,
altri fratelli del mare,
potessero morire proprio come lui.
Allora ho subito pensato che dovevamo dare
a questo capodoglio una nuova casa,
però questa volta molto più sicura,
che potesse comunicare qualcosa a tutti.
Non mi sono --
con un po' di stomaco forte,
mi sono immerso in quell'acqua,
normalmente gli spiaggiamenti
avvengono nelle spiagge, appunto.
Quindi si ha tutta la comodità
di aprire la pancia,
di scarnificare, vestiti.
In quel caso invece il capodoglio
era tutto immerso nell'acqua
non c'era possibilità di portarlo via.
E quindi mi sono dovuto calare
con una muta dentro quell'acqua
per poter, appunto, prendere le ossa.
E vi assicuro
che non era proprio profumata
non era Chanel N°5.
Ancora se non ci credete potete sentire
che faccio un po' di profumo.
Ma, aprendo la pancia del capodoglio,
ho trovato al suo interno
moltissima plastica.
Addirittura c'era un vaso da giardinaggio
che aveva letteralmente masticato
e ingoiato.
Con grande sforzo e stomaco forte,
in solo 15 giorni, ho completamente
scarnificato questo capodoglio
tirato a terra tutte le ossa,
con l'idea fortissima di fare, appunto,
questo museo del mare,
che non esisteva a Milazzo.
Proprio per dare voce al capodoglio Siso.
Purtroppo, il giorno dopo questo recupero,
un caro amico, Francesco,
che mi aveva aiutato
a portare a terra le ossa,
ha avuto un terribile incidente
con lo scooter.
Una tragedia nella tragedia.
Francesco perde la vita
in questo incidente terribile
e quindi i due destini che si intrecciano
mi portano a far nominare il capodoglio,
a battezzarlo proprio
con il nome di Francesco,
anzi con il soprannome,
con cui io normalmente lo chiamavo
così affettuosamente: Siso.
Da quel giorno diventò il capodoglio Siso.
Proprio l'altro giorno un bambino
a scuola mi disse:
"Ma a te chi l'aveva detto
che si chiamava capodoglio Siso?"
E in effetti ho raccontato questa storia.
Così il capodoglio arriva a terra,
le ossa erano incredibilmente
ricche di grasso.
Diciamo che il vero lavoro
stava per cominciare.
È stato un lavoro molto difficile
perché ho deciso di non utilizzare
sostanze chimiche,
soltanto acqua calda e acqua ossigenata,
proprio per evitare
che le ossa del capodoglio Siso
potessero inquinarsi
con le stesse sostanze chimiche
che vanno a uccidere
tantissimi animali del mare.
Quindi per un anno sono stato a contatto
con questa grande quantità di grasso.
Questo ha avuto degli aspetti
molto negativi ma anche positivi,
infatti non devo più usare,
praticamente, prodotti per le mani
le ho sempre morbidissime.
Fino a quel punto ho fatto tutto da solo
ma è arrivato il momento
di rendere pubblico
quello che era successo.
Tante persone mi dovevano aiutare
per arrivare all'obiettivo,
a rispondere a quel grido di aiuto
del capodoglio Siso.
E così, proprio sui social ho lanciato
il "Siso Project".
E sono arrivati degli aiuti
da tutte le parti del mondo.
Da tantissime persone:
professionisti, artisti,
semplici persone che,
versando col crowdfunding,
anche cinque dieci euro,
hanno permesso di realizzare,
di arrivare
all'incredibile cifra di 30.000 euro,
per realizzare il sogno.
Questo che vedete
è il logo del Siso Project,
che è stato regalato da una ragazza,
che non mi conosceva,
mi ha contattato sui social
e mi ha detto: "Guarda,
ho fatto questo logo, ti piace?"
Ho detto: "Fantastico!"
Questo rende l'idea di cosa è successo.
Tantissime persone che non conoscevano me,
che non conoscevano il capodoglio Siso,
sono state investite da quella
che io chiamo la "Siso Power"
questa energia positiva,
che ha permesso di portare
alla costruzione del museo stesso.
Quindi una rete che uccide il capodoglio,
una rete illegale
che uccide il capodoglio,
quindi una rete negativa,
diventa così una rete positiva,
la rete positiva umana
la rete umana che si unisce
e fa tornare in vita un capodoglio,
morto, appunto, per cause antropiche.
Quello che vedete è il logo
del Siso Project,
con tutti i nomi delle persone
che hanno contribuito a questo progetto
e che rimarrà per sempre all'interno
del museo.
Sono più di 1.000 nomi.
Eccoci quindi al nostro museo.
È stato finalmente realizzato,
ci troviamo al castello di Milazzo.
Quello che vedete è lo scheletro
del capodoglio Siso
all'interno di una chiesa,
la chiesa di Santa Maria,
costruita, pensate, nel 1527.
Il capodoglio Siso è posizionato
perfettamente dove c'era l'altare
dell'antica chiesa.
Proprio per dare un senso di sacralità
alla storia del capodoglio Siso.
Questa chiesa poi
viene trasformata, negli anni,
e diventa invece un bastione,
appunto il bastione di Santa Maria
come l'omonima chiesa.
Quindi il capodoglio all'interno
è un po' come protetto
da questo baluardo, da questo castello.
Una protezione, appunto,
un paladino dell'ecologia,
potremmo definirlo.
Quando ho messo insieme
tutte le ossa del capodoglio,
l'ho ricostruito dopo tanti viaggi
in giro per l'Italia e per l'Europa
con consigli anche
da tutte le parti del mondo,
anche dall'Alaska, addirittura, pensate,
ho deciso di posizionare il capodoglio,
non a un'altezza esagerata.
Tutti mi dicevano:
"Ma tu il capodoglio
lo devi mettere in modo tale
che non possano toccarlo le persone!"
No, no, al contrario!
Volevo che le persone,
non dico "toccassero il capodoglio"
ma entrassero perfettamente
in empatia con il capodoglio stesso,
si avvicinassero
per potersi rendere conto veramente
e potessero toccare
la morte del capodoglio.
Ma è l'unica cosa morta in tutto il museo.
È un museo fatto per i bambini.
Quindi è l'unica cosa morta
di tutto il museo,
anzi al contrario, adesso tramite
un'applicazione di realtà aumentata
il capodoglio prende vita
e ritorna a vivere veramente
in modo tale che i bambini
hanno imparato la lezione
del capodoglio che può morire
ma che può anche tornare a parlare.
E sono loro proprio
i veri protagonisti del museo:
i bambini che ogni giorno vengono al museo
e si appassionano a questo capodoglio
e portano dentro sé un messaggio molto
importante che poi trasmettono
agli altri bambini e soprattutto
ai genitori e ai grandi,
perché è proprio quella la fascia
che dobbiamo andare a colpire;
attraverso i bambini,
andare ad arrivare ai grandi.
Inoltre, oltre
a queste applicazioni moderne,
al museo, tutt'attorno al capodoglio,
ci sono tantissime opere d'arte
e si arriva appunto a parlare
del capodoglio, dell'ambientalismo,
proprio attraverso l'arte,
la realtà virtuale, che appassiona tanto,
non dico i bambini ma praticamente tutti.
Questo ha comportato
che tantissime persone
si sono veramente
appassionate di ambiente,
di questo povero capodoglio morto.
E quindi proprio nella spiaggia
vicino a dove il capodoglio è morto,
si sono raccolte centinaia di persone
per prendere la spazzatura.
Abbiamo raccolto
più di due tir di spazzatura
e l'abbiamo portata via.
Ci sono stati un'altra serie di eventi
che ho fatto
dopo l'inaugurazione del museo,
come ad esempio questa traversata
dello stretto di Messina a nuoto,
trascinando con me un bel po' di plastica,
per dare quell'idea di questo fardello
che l'uomo si porta
da una parte all'altra del mondo.
Non avevo considerato
che c'era un bel po' di corrente
e quindi questo coso fungeva
praticamente da paracadute
e mi stava trascinando fino in Sardegna.
Ma questa è soltanto
una cosa così, un particolare.
Un'altra cosa che ho fatto
sempre quest'estate,
è stata di partire con questa piccola
barca a vela di quattro metri
senza il motore, soltanto spinto
dal vento delle isole Eolie
ho fatto il periplo di tutte le isole,
con una finalità precisa,
che non era solo quella di mangiare
e farmi i bagni che ho fatto,
ma soprattutto di portare la voce
del capodoglio Siso
e far conoscere a tutti quanti
questa storia importante
e anche valorizzare il patrimonio
naturalistico della nostra terra.
Un'altra conseguenza della morte
e della rinascita di questo capodoglio
è stato che nel 2018, e anche quest'anno,
un'associazione,
che si chiama Sea Shepherd,
ha fatto un'operazione di pulizia
del nostro mare
da tutte quelle armi illegali
che uccidono il nostro mare
e che hanno ucciso
anche il capodoglio Siso.
Per intenderci, Sea Shepherd
sono quegli amici, i pirati buoni,
che si vedono in tutto il mondo
anche a ostacolare
quelle operazioni
di bracconaggio delle balene.
Ma ecco qui finalmente
la foto, per me più bella,
la soddisfazione più grande,
ovvero i bambini felici
sotto il capodoglio.
Quel capodoglio che non è più
simbolo di morte,
ma è simbolo di vita,
un capodoglio che parla,
quella stessa voce che mi parlava
quando lui era morto,
parla anche ai bambini oggi al museo.
E li vedete, sono lì felici,
sono loro che, veramente, mi portano --
portano delle cose incredibili.
Molto spesso, per esempio,
i genitori mi chiamano
e mi dicono: "Disgraziato!
Mio figlio mi dice
che non devo più mangiare la neonata,
oppure che dobbiamo usare meno plastica."
Io sono molto felice di questo.
i bambini, finalmente riescono
a dare una lezione ai genitori.
Infine, io penso che noi abbiamo
veramente un obbligo importante
nei confronti di questi bambini.
Un detto Navajo dice appunto che:
"Non ereditiamo la terra dai nostri padri"
non abbiamo soltanto l'obbligo di farlo
perché l'abbiamo preso in eredità
dai nostri genitori,
ma la prendiamo in prestito
dai nostri figli".
Quindi abbiamo una doppia responsabilità
e se non lo facciamo per noi,
almeno lo dobbiamo fare per loro.
(Applausi)